hell I think it's time we did something
about so come on hello females 20th
century basically there's a leading
cleric in Iran that made the statement
last week that women dressing immodestly
leads to men's urges being incited and
this causes earthquakes and so a student
at Purdue decided that that was too
ridiculous to let go and so she
initiated boobquake which is basically
the idea that women should dress
immodestly on Monday today and just see
exactly what kind of seismic you know
movement we can cause and if not then we
can prove that claim wrong all across
the country this thing grew so quickly I
mean by yesterday there were several
hundred hundred thousand women who had
joined up with this cause and I think
that a lot of them who were unable to
come out to dupont circle or go to one
of the big organized areas you know
we're in their workplace show in there
you know boobs for to support the cause
because if he's going to make his
ridiculous statement like that i think
you know one good way to counter it is
sort of a little bit tongue-in-cheek and
add some humor into it yeah i would say
anything with the word boob in it it's
probably going to be a little bit lesson
completely serious but the intent is
serious just to basically discredit the
idea and bring attention to the fact
that this is a leading advisor in this
country and this is what women in that
country are being told that it is
because they dress immodestly that
causes earthquakes and we couldn't let
that go and gals let's get into the
swing of things keep your boobie some
freedom Oh
not you're not que paso